good morning Hank it's Tuesday I like
the 16 minutes of your Friday video so
much I thought I'd do a 16 part video of
my own today part 1 the intro dawn part
to our one-week fundraiser for save the
children's work with Syrian refugees has
raised over $15,000 which means 30
thousand dollars with matching which is
a lot of money and it makes me feel
better about the world in general and my
post-operative mouth pain in particular
so thank you
part three our podcast it's gonna be
called dear Hank and John or as I like
to think of it Dear John and Hank it'll
feature us answering questions from
nerdfighters and dispensing second-rate
advice and giving you the latest news
from AFC Wimbledon and Mars sir fighters
if you want to send us a question or a
problem you can do so we're at Hank and
John at gmail.com part four and the
meanwhile you can listen to the tour
because awesome podcast featuring Hank
and his friends link in the doobly-doo
part 5 Hank last night I had this weird
dream that my friend Hannah Hart was a
professional trapeze artist working with
the trapeze collective called the Flyers
with a Z no real story there I just
wanted to share that image with you part
six hank dftba records has a new CEO Jo
garrett she's great and she's a
nerdfighter and she's gonna help dftba
records get people awesome stuff in a
timely manner I'm so bad at counting
what part are we on I don't even know
part five I'm gonna say part seven Rosie
onna is here I think we have stolen
rosianna halse rojas away from her
native land of england and brought her
here to the united states with a fancy
visa I can't yet reveal to you the full
awesomeness of this but soon anyway part
8 nerdfighteria sponsored AFC Wimbledon
are going to stay in league two again
which is great news they finished the
season in 15th so they are still a
full-time professional team and if you
play the next FIFA game you can still be
AFC Wimbledon and see our shorts in
video game form we also have some of
these awesome nerdfighteria Wimbledon
scarves still available at dftba.com
link in the dooblydoo part 9 in case
you're wondering why I'm in front of
this white wall new video background
coming soon part 10 over at hankgames
I'm currently taking a moral journey
through the video game Grand Theft Auto
exploring the question of whether people
truly wield power or the will to
our ultimately wields people also how do
you play this game without running over
people's feet part 11 Bank of
nerdfighteria update so like ad revenue
from this channel vlogbrothers gets
split in half between the foundation to
decrease worldsuck nerdfighteria charity
and a fund that sponsors educational
content online like physics girl in the
financial diet so far for this year the
foundation to decrease worldsuck has
raised about forty thousand dollars
mostly from people watching ads on
vlogbrothers so thank you for ingesting
all of that advertising but we've also
gotten a bunch of money from tab for a
cause a browser extension that allows
you to make money for charity just by
surfing the web it really does work it
was built by nerdfighters there is a
link in the doobly-doo part 12 if you
are a teacher or student who uses crash
course in school your life is about to
get better because thanks to Bill Gates
we are building curricular materials
around the videos like lesson plans and
primary sources and other stuff that I
don't understand very well because I'm
not an educator but look for that stuff
rolling out before the new school year
alright 13 - Paper Towns movie think the
Paper Towns movie comes out in like 56
days in the United States it comes out
at different times in different places
why I don't know the movie business is
strange but I will be traveling around
the world to support the release of the
Paper Towns movie at least going to
Brazil and the United Kingdom and also
probably some other places I hope I get
to meet lots of nerdfighters part 14
July 24th is not just the release day of
Paper Towns it's also the first day of
VidCon oh that should be a relaxing day
anyway VidCon tickets are probably gonna
sell out in the next couple weeks so
don't get mad at me for not saying
anything about how they were about to
sell out because I just said something
part 15 oh my god I can't believe the
Paper Towns movie comes out in less than
two months it makes me feel that a weird
fear excitement strangly throat thing do
you know that thing I have a complicated
relationship with that feeling Hank but
all things considered I would recommend
it over mouth pain part 16 the outro
Hank I will see you on Friday